taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
what's up taste buddies it's the taste
buds podcast
i'm jodorosa i'm sal volcano we're here
to debate some food today
oh my god today we have a humdinger
i can't i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait
till we get to it because we let's just
warm up a little bit first with some
comments
is it 2-2 right now it's 2-2 right now
it is right yeah
four we've done four episodes you one
two i won two okay
and after this episode i will have won
three
yeah this is one where i will say you're
coming out confident and you're
good reason to be but these are two
heavyweights that we're debating today
it's a heavyweight it's not really a
i took a i did bad with the peach with
the peach pie i should have did cherry
pie we all said that we all know that
uh i don't know that i would have
accepted the challenge had it been
cherry pie
you still would have won with apple
there's no no one's gonna beat apple no
yeah but i do i do have an admiration
for cherry pie well we've
we don't need to get into it but here's
the point it's not always something we
hate it's
just our preference but if we hate it
it's even better yeah so i don't want to
announce just yet
what we're debating today okay let's
just have some friendly food talk
we were just talking before we started
rolling yes the uh uh the concept of
bringing food to bed
oh yeah and i said in my 30s i often
brought food to bed and would fall
asleep with it now when i was in my 30s
this is what i want to tell you
yeah every night not every night but
five nights a week i would go out i'd
get hammered with my buddies at a comedy
club whatever we were doing
and then on the way home i would get a
cheese steak
sometimes double meat from the deli i
like it
uh a nemo's chocolate cake square
and a coke oh and and put an
oh and probably chips you saw
you say that to me now and i'm like oh
my god my inside yeah yeah
and i would lay in my bed i'd put my tv
on i'd lay in my bed i mean it's a feast
for a king
yeah just [ __ ] face and i'd eat it yeah
i'd get through a lot of it
okay do you want all of it you know i
know what my go-to was please
okay well first of all like in college i
worked at a pizzeria as a delivery guy
so at the end of the night we didn't
throw the pizza away i took it home i uh
so working three nights a week four
nights a week i used to come home with
like two pies
and then i just keep it in the fridge
and whoever came over the cold pizza i
just lived off of it that's great
my go-to when i bartended for a long
time and i just like come home
i only place open like these bodegas or
convenience stores 24 hours uh-huh
so i didn't have like really cheese
steak available to me my late-night
drunk
or was that yeah i guess sometimes i was
drinking but this was my go-to snack and
let me tell you i
i didn't realize how bad it was for me
then but it helped me
just pack on some some mess
give it to me cream cheese everything
a bagel of tropicana orange juice okay
all right and the hostess black cupcakes
with the
the white the on the ice i know what you
mean and the cream in the middle the
cream in the middle but it's chocolate
everything chocolate except the swirl of
white with the cream in the middle okay
that was my
boom boom boom like i i would go home
after a night and i'd just be like
i can't wait to eat like i was going to
eat a michelin rank
look at that thing it's often um
imitated but
rarely uh duplicated it's uh i even had
it i've even had it like
some really like some uh bakeries try to
make it
and they don't even make it as good but
although i will say like everything else
that's dropped off in quality i mean i
don't mean anything
shout out hostess but look that's a
heavy heavy carb sugar meal
which i uh see my thing was always like
my late night thing
you had the nemo's the coca-cola i would
say cheesesteak
and doritos i would set up no but no no
no but i
i would set up something that felt more
like a dinner like it was like you know
what i mean like yeah but you have a
heroes a hero's worth of bread yeah
besides the thing but i'm saying i'm
surprised at the lack of
meat involved in your me you know i was
i mean this was i was
you know 4 30 in the morning at the deli
yeah i wasn't gonna have to chop me up a
steak no i was
i'm saying i'm saying you're more of a
sweets kind of guy i think and i was a
little more in the direction of uh
yeah i mean i don't know pounding a hot
foot long cheesesteak at 5am
i'm not above it but i just think like a
nice everything bagel hit the spot a
little more
a little more uh why why
um is it the cheese sticks are too heavy
for you
at that time right before bed
you don't have the you don't have the
balls
it's a bit much it's going to repeat on
me of course
i was already going and i was already
dipping a big toe in with the with the
oj
yeah i now sleep i don't go anywhere i
don't leave my house without a writing
utensil
uh a pen or a pencil and tum how much oj
that's just a 16 ounce a 16 ounce yeah
which by the way i don't know if they
sell those anymore you know my problem
with that
yeah no we'll get to it in a plastic
bottle or the cardboard carton
yeah the plastic tropicanas are
disgusting no no not i mean
not from concentrate you give me
concentrate orange juice literally i'll
i'll slap your mother in the mouth
really yes really you like orange juice
we're going to get to that
it's my favorite drink of all time
although i will say in the last
in the last five years i i rarely rarely
have it uh i was also a pizza delivery
man
okay and i'll tell you real quick i said
did i say boy or ma'am
or did i just say whenever i say no no
because i was like in college i was
never
i did a pizza delivery boy people don't
normally say a pizza delivery
pizza delivery guy i thought that i had
the face of a man with the heart of a
boy
okay all right uh i'll tell you my two
greatest defensives
uh delivering food uh from the deli yeah
the pizza slash deli place i worked at
oh there's your problem right there
first of all what what
unbelievable what do you mean the pizza
slash
deli place no it was a pizza shop that
also sold like sandwiches and [ __ ]
but just italian sandwiches yeah and
like they they would make a turkey club
and stuff like you know like like
was it a pizzeria that's all sandwiches
was it a sandwich
slash pizza place i worked in both
primarily what was it
i worked in both i worked at a pizzeria
that was primarily a pizzeria that also
sold cheese steaks and a little bit of
pasta and stuff like that that's fine
that's because then i worked in a deli
that didn't serve anything but
sandwiches okay okay cause some of these
delis try to get away with like
i see like these places like the jersey
shore place sort of they'll be like
yeah we're a sub shop but we also make
pizza or what have you it's like
you don't really do both well in philly
every almost every pizza place philly's
pizza and subs subs and you mean heroes
right
hoagies we call them hoagies but you
mean eggplant chicken
meatballs peppers and eggs yeah like
meatball and cheese but you don't have
chicken parmesan
like tuna turkey club you know an
italian italian hoagie turkey hoagie
you know that stuff too yeah i really
no no i worked in a pizzeria that like
didn't really make like
we might have had a couple of but on
staten island you worked in a pizzeria
yeah
we do it different in philly yeah i'm
saying you do it wrong
we we do it better okay because you can
go into a pizza
you want to get you want to i want to
get a hoagie at my favorite pizza
why wouldn't you want to get a hoagie at
your favorite pizza don't get me wrong
an italian hero that would be on an
italian menu but
not like uh you know i'm not going to go
in there and get something that's not
like that you could only get in like a a
delicatessen
we're here's what i'm offended by right
now
you're talking as if these pizzerias i'm
referring to are these are these
[ __ ] bodegas that we have here in the
fine city
over there when you i'm not talking
about a bodega where you go in they've
got a candy bar section
and and then a ho ho section okay and
then a coffee machine well i'm talking
about it's a pizzeria that also makes
sam that's that's the two things they do
sandwich and i'm talking real sandwiches
i'm not talking boar's head
sliced and tossed going i mean shout out
boy's head though
i love boar's head yeah but i'm talking
about you get a real italian sandwich
okay i don't think you know i mean i i
worked in a pizza
this is very sensitive territory for me
okay listen
you want you you're stepping on my story
too because i was just going to tell you
a funny story
and you felt the need to go in and take
start taking pot shots
about you you told me at the top of this
thing you got competitive and you said
i'm going down you are and you set the
tone you are i can't
i could be on your side i could be your
ally or i could be your enemy do you
want to hear the story
yes my greatest defense is delivery
please tell me
one time for the pizza place uh somebody
ordered fried mushrooms
they were mushrooms and breading that
was it yeah and uh
i dropped them on the way to the car
they rolled out of the styrofoam
an oil stain on the macadam i picked
them up put them back
it didn't say anything
somebody might be dead on my watch i
don't even know
i can't even laugh at it i'm mortified
that means that that means that it's
happening to everybody because if you if
you're out there other people like you
were out there
yeah i mean i wouldn't i would have i
mean i would have went back to the place
and be like look i dropped it
i didn't i couldn't face getting
screamed at
an oil stain oh
[ __ ] oh guys it's okay it was just a
stain you know like on a parking lot
uh no no i know yeah on the ground
we were on the earth we were so behind
and i was already getting grief for my
boss that day and i couldn't i know
i know when you're in the weeds yeah you
don't want to go back i've done it i i
had bad offenses too
i would take like sometimes when it was
just dinners and not pizzas or even
pizzas about dinners we put it in like
the cheese boxes like
and so we'd have like a carrying case
and i'd like go to get in the car and
go to put the thing on the roof then
open the car and then
one time i one time i put it on the roof
got in the car
drove to the place then i got there i
knew where i was going and i looked in
the car and i was like oh my god i
didn't
right i forgot to bring the food so i'm
like oh my god i gotta go all the way
back and come back and be late
so i'm just getting my car and i just
drive back yeah but as i'm driving back
um there's a two-lane uh highway uh or
street over the
expressway and so you go back one way
and you come back the other way
and i'm driving and i see just like like
bird hawks
seagulls everything just in the middle
of the street just descending down like
15
birds and i'm looking at driving i go
that is the into people's entire meal
it was on my roof and it fell off over
there and by the time i got back they
attacked it
i love it because my second offense
was the same thing that's on the roof
club sandwich from the deli
drove off saw the styrofoam
fly off of my roof in front of my
windshield yeah it tumbled
opened up on the ground okay now now the
sandwich stayed in the styrofoam
but it was it was disastrous yeah you
delivered it ready for this
yo this was a place by the way beep that
this was a place
i said f earlier too beep it uh this was
a place where
you really got screamed at like if you
like yeah but but there's also a matter
of public safe
health okay so what i did was i picked
it up i reassembled the sandwich which
didn't touch the ground
it didn't touch the ground i fixed the
sandwich yes it was i
closed on your hood no no the container
hit the ground but the sandwich stayed
in the container like it never came out
of the container
so i fixed the sandwich in the street i
i closed the container
the container has now black scuffs on it
and i just my hand to god gravel stones
are stuck in it
that i'm picking out i deliver
it but i was delivering to a business so
the lady that
who it was for like she didn't get it
like i left it at the front desk
and the money was there i leave it i
think i got away with bloody murder i
drive back
i walk into the uh deli and my boss
looks at me and he goes
what the hell did you do to that club
sandwich they called
[Laughter]
i'll tell you i totally got away with it
i told this story in a podcast before
um i don't remember where but uh the
worst thing i ever did in the only time
i ever did it here i am giving you guff
um i had a lady that used to order
the same thing every like every couple
afternoons
and when you had a day shift it was
already slow and she always used to
order my day shift
uh and she looked i i was gonna say the
address i wanted to say the address
and she ordered a regular slice a
sicilian slice and a can of coca-cola
classic
and it was 4.95 okay and every day
i would deliver it to her two slices in
a paper bag with a can of coca-cola
and ring the bell she'd take forever to
get to the door and then when she got to
the door she'd open the door
and like be like oh hey how are you oh
my goodness i would give her it and
she'd give me
exactly 4.95
she wouldn't give me a five dollar
billion right she'd give me four
ninety five right so she didn't tip me a
red cent
and it was annoying and i just didn't
like her and she had she had a treadmill
in our house and all she did was hang
out clothes on it
right yeah full disclosure yeah okay so
i was
like this ended up happening for like
months and one time i got so upset with
her
so what'd you do
all right so one time i was like that
was a deep silence you just gave
us something real one time i go there
and she gives me a manila envelope
like the the big ones like a letter size
and she goes i'm so sorry
um i looked around and i didn't have
uh the like i didn't have the money and
i didn't couldn't find the bills
so i just put it like in change and she
goes here and she goes but i did put
something in there for you
she said those words okay exactly like
that she's just something in there for
you
i'm holding this thing it's five pounds
it feels like like
three pounds excuse my cursing again
three pounds
three pounds i open it
it's only pennies yeah only
yeah so i said you know what because my
boss used to be a
delivery minimum so he's not i'm not
getting hung out to dry but he would he
wouldn't enforce it with this woman
right so i'm like now i'm gonna show my
boss her true colors yeah so i go in
i walk up and i'm walking on that
envelope he's standing behind the
counter and i walk
down the counter on the other side and
he goes what's that and i open it and i
just dump 500 pennies on the camera
i drop dumped the pennies on the counter
and he goes what is that and i go
it's the lady you make me deliver to
every day that never tips me and he goes
i've never
he goes i've i've never in my entire
life in my this entire business run
ever seen anything like in my life i go
i told you and then i start to count it
he's like don't count it he goes i'm
going to tell i'm gonna call her on the
phone
i'm gonna say we're gonna return it back
i can't use this money and just to pay
me when she has it
okay so he gets on the phone he tells it
i i counted it
just because i wanted to see because she
said there's something in there for you
4.95
there was 500 pennies yeah i know and
and it's a shame
she left me five pounds you let it slip
early you blew it early
it's a shame i haven't told the story in
a while it's okay i know it's
i know i let it get we could beep it
then and then you can act like you can
now this whole thing's gonna be beeped
all right yeah 500 so i didn't tell you
what i did
oh what'd you do next time she ordered
what'd you do i thought you were going
to say like you spit in the pizza or
something i did oh you did
yeah i didn't reveal that you're giving
me [ __ ]
it only did it once only to this woman
only once
i never did anything like that you got
caster
beep these curses you got castor motor
oil in your friend's
egg turkey i was under the gun that was
different i didn't do it maliciously
i know but you still did it you made a
you made it you knew what happened
no you do you don't spit in somebody's
food when somebody doesn't tip you you
walk away
muttering you're dirty under your breath
and you're in your car yeah
never would have bitten her but when she
tipped me five pennies it was the
breaking point
[Laughter]
god i just you could go to jail for that
that's a song that's why i'm joking
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's why i'm
joking you're past whatever the statue
it is you're past
that's why you're right i am right i
spit right now food
but i never did it i would never do that
i mean look you're talking to the i am a
pillar of excellence
at every job i've ever done i've taken
two i go the extra mile
go out of my way bend over backwards
customer always right i teach i taught
my staff that when i had it when i had
my own place
never in my life have i ever even
peripherally visited
that dark place in my mind but this
woman
was so annoying and and then when she
just took me five pennies yet
i've already had delivered to her house
50 times she had something on your boss
she was bla there was something i don't
know you know but i
if my golf would be my boss ever sees
this man because i i feel like
i'm by telling it i'm letting him down
because i really take everything
really like i really work like when i do
my job
no matter what it is i try to really
really i know i know and so look
here we are all having a moment right
i'm sharing this moment with people i'm
sharing with you listen this is
vulnerable
yeah i i i'm ashamed of it uh yes would
i do it today no i wouldn't do it today
um do i feel like i could have done it
again uh i mean do i feel like i i was
justified back then
no it's probably never justifiable i i
have a clean bill of health she's fine
uh i i just i
should i be ashamed right now no no why
because i'm judging you
i'm just everyone knows because it's fun
to judge but everybody is going to judge
me now
18 who cares yeah yeah that's okay i
believe 18 is an adult
it's fine i wouldn't worry about it you
think you're the first pizza guy to spit
in some ladies pizza probably not
no but now you know you know once you
spit now all of a sudden i'm the guy
that does that
uh you're not the guy that does that i
don't think anybody's going to think
that you're the guy that does it i
promise you no it's never
going to cross my mind and i've been in
the food service industry my whole life
that was the only time ever
i probably did something like that along
the line somewhere
it's like what kind of passive
aggressive [ __ ] is giving me a
manila envelope of 500 pennies in it
and saying going out of your way to say
why now
she's a winner she was a lunatic so she
thinks the five cents is a good question
she's
not a sane person right she's not saying
you're talking as if you're dealing with
the
you know the the secretary of state
right right it's a lunatic okay
okay okay well then well how do you feel
about what i did then
i don't have a problem with it it's just
more fun to be judgmental
i mean did you think this guy would
understand a podcast work by now
yeah let's agree on everything no i do
understand that's why i'm
doing it i'm i'm digging in deep here
all right i'm giving you i'm giving you
stuff to bounce off
i'm bouncing babe i'm bouncing but let's
get to it because i don't want to run
out of time okay
uh i want to get to the debate that you
are going to
this is we might be like 20 minutes in
already yeah
are we you want to talk about a lunatic
you want to talk about a crazy person
here's one this is a big one to debate
here's a debate get
ready to launch it onto twitter folks
are you ready for this debate
best classic ice cream flavor
chocolate or vanilla tweet
done it's out why don't you tell the
fine people which side you
tell you right now chocolate has a
flavor i love it i'm a chocoholic
i'm addicted to chocolate i wish
chocolate didn't exist because chocolate
has put a lot of
mass on my body personally and i love
chocolate in a lot of different
iterations
and i do not even mind chocolate in an
ice cream flavor listen to this
justification when you go head to head
in an ice cream flavored chocolate
versus vanilla
i go vanilla 10 times out of 10. without
a doubt
i don't think that chocolate really does
itself
justice in an ice cream flavor it's like
ch
ice cream's version of chocolate whereas
with vanilla
i think ice cream does vanilla a service
i think it elevates vanilla
the bean the madagascar vanilla bean who
wants it elevated it's a [ __ ] flavor
that nobody needs elevated
don't get me wrong i'm not talking about
i'm not going to the places you go to
get your ice cream okay no no no i
i don't know what are you buying where
are you going the last time i had ice
cream you bought it for me
and i wouldn't have touched the vanilla
in that shop listen to me vanilla
i think i and i and you know what you ca
you came in here and
and you think you're gonna dominate with
chocolate because just because of course
i am well but
because chocolate should be the favorite
right now because chocolate in in other
iterations is a thing
but i think you're gonna be surprised at
the people that
that come together for for a vanilla ice
cream
oh god i'm sorry no i just i just think
you're discrediting
how good a good a good vanilla ice cream
is better than a good chocolate ice
cream
you're you're insane okay nobody i am
just like a vanilla shake is better than
a chocolate chicken
you're not you're you think of it please
beep the curse you're nuts you are
insane if you think of chocolate
you're nuts a vanilla shake a chocolate
shake that's insane a chocolate shake
has
nothing i i believe a vanilla shake
dominates chocolate chick even more than
vanilla ice cream
dominates chocolate ice cream itself but
it's the same thing it's the same
argument we wouldn't have another
episode for you okay
okay no maybe we cannot though maybe we
should have an addendum to this episode
not for a full episode but i just want
to piggyback even right now
let's go shake as well right now we'll
do two poles no no no no no let's save
shake
let's save shake let's save shake well i
mean i think this
this poll is gonna be a good indicator
as to what the shake pulls
don't worry about it you're getting
ahead of yourself okay and you're
getting your hair so you're not letting
me
put my argument in okay well i've just
finished speaking now that's how you go
that's how debate goes okay
okay you ready for this nobody in
history in the history of ice cream
has walked into an ice cream shop and
said can i have a vanilla cone please
nobody you get vanilla ice cream what do
you got to do you dump hot fudge all
over it you put it in a cup
in a pretzel cup with chocolate whatever
uh magic shell on it you put it inside a
clown duck by
klondike bar because it cannot carry
water on its own
no chocolate ice cream give me a big
bowl of it i'll eat it straight down
plain by itself the reason you put it
with everything else is because vanilla
elevates every other thing and is so
versatile that it complements everything
you want to throw in it you
don't do that with chocolate because
chocolate is a little bit it's just
overpowering everything doesn't need it
vanilla is complimentary vanilla
compliments every other ingredient
chocolate overpowers every other
ingredient ice cream is the melania
trumps of ice cream
useless but looks good next to something
else
that's what it is that's what it is and
i don't mean that in a sexist way
something that you called not good made
it to first lady of the united states
so what she had to do to get there all
right
i don't even know what that means trump
look with vanilla
vanilla has to trump itself to get onto
my plate
it's got a it's got to put a very good
i gotta be honest like like you give me
a beautiful like
variation of a chocolate bar from light
to dark chocolate
give me uh a beautiful fudge uh a moose
even i'll take a chocolate pudding i
love chocolate i love chocolate candy i
love it
but as an ice cream
look every picture it's with something
else
that's because it's amazing it's because
the classic haagen-dazs dipped chocolate
almond is vanilla based
the classic chipwich is vanilla based
the classic flying saucer is vanilla
chocolate taco cook cookie dough goes
with vanilla cookies and cream it goes
with vanilla
an ice cream sundae you usually use
vanilla not chocolate
we're talking ice cream versus ice cream
you would never eat a bowl of vanilla
ice cream by itself
i don't know who you are and where you
came from
but what you just said i makes
absolutely no sense that's all i've done
my entire life
a couple of moments ago you said no one
would ever walk into an ice cream shop
and say
let me have a vanilla cone well i don't
know the last time you were in an ice
cream shop
but i bet you dollars to donuts fine
with me with you a month ago
great okay and i bet you if we stood
there two seconds longer someone come in
and say i'll have a vanilla coke you're
out of your mind okay
right all right you're out of your mind
okay you're out of your mind let me tell
you what neapolitan looks like when i
throw it away
all vanilla's still in there all vanilla
because you hate it
that's ridiculous you're not even you're
not even embracing what the
is about which is a bite a different
flavor in every bite i look at vanilla i
actually really like strawberry ice
cream as well i'll tell you what i like
strawberry ice cream better than
chocolate
that's fine that's not the debate though
and that's not the side you check you
chose you had a chance you could have
chose that and maybe he had a chance at
winning
this nobody is picking don't vanish
ice cream over chocolate ice cream i
don't care if chocolate wins
it's not better but you're saying i have
no chance of winning this i think you're
going to be surprised when it comes to
ice cream how many people will pivot
vanilla okay
i'm telling you there's something about
just a rich creamy smooth vanilla taste
sometimes chocolate tastes like
processed manufactured chocolate if
you're not going to a really
artisanal spot sometimes anything tastes
like that what kind of argument is that
soft serve you go vanilla or chocolate
chocolate you're bat [ __ ] crazy i'm not
and i'll go
mix i'll go mix sometimes but i'm not
going vanilla are you
nuts you're nuts come on man get out of
here
rainbow sprinkles on a chocolate cone
what are you a sociopath i don't use
sprinkles
what are you jimmys no i don't i don't
it's a waste
sprinkles are waste yeah like whipped
creams are always just like whipped
cream whipped cream is a waste outlet
now you see now where he's coming from
in this whole entire argument a man that
thinks sprinkles and whipped cream
are a waste what do you get me about ice
cream what do you get out of sprinkles
aside from the fact that it tastes like
you put plastic on top of your ice cream
i don't know where you're getting your
sprinkles oh please
i guess i get up i get a burst a
colorful burst of energy and
flavor and fun and texture yeah
look fine okay if you want to argue that
they add texture
look at a cone that is doused in in
rainbow sprinkles
it is fun you said what do i get it's
fun it
it it's it's vibrant it it it it runs
down the
vanilla and it dyes the vanilla all
different colors which makes it even
more fun
and then you bite into it you get the
texture versus the creaminess
can i go on about sprinkles i'll tell
you what i'll do i'll tell you what i do
i'll get a chocolate cone chocolate
sauce serve with chocolate sprinkles
out of spite i'll do it out of spicy
rainbow sprinkles aren't vanilla
sprinkles so that spite analogy does not
work no i'm saying i'm going to double
up on the chocolate i'm going to get
chocolate sprinkles on top of chocolate
sauce
i don't not like chocolate ice cream
does that make sense well
you're you're talking a real i mean but
but
but when you put it against vanilla
manila
i'm sorry about it sorry you like these
foods
i like vanilla icing better than
chocolate ice cream you like these [ __ ]
foods
that have to be added into things this
is this was your choreographer
vanilla vanilla this was your oreo
vanilla bean is
yeah is a beautiful superior vanilla
item dessert
it's a [ __ ] food you think it's a [ __ ]
food i'll say nobody thinks vanilla is
[ __ ]
uh vanilla is i'll say it again vanilla
is in everything [ __ ] food okay
[ __ ] food vanilla like cream soda it's
the most disgusting soda on planet earth
cream soda is delicious
oh mark it down in my in my verse is
what though versus words
i think cream soda is the most
disgusting soda and drink to ever exist
and if you think it's delicious
we got a nice debate the right cream
soda is terrific
it's the what do i take something over
it i mean all like
like figure it out later health aside i
like root beer probably better
i also like a black cherry soda better
but i don't really drink these things
we'll we'll we'll work we'll work it out
later but i'm telling you
you're correct i mean you think it's
you're gonna have like a burger at a w
with a nice cream soda
i think or a hot dog off the truck with
a cream soda i'll show you
i think cream soda boiling is the most
disgusting drink
to ever exist what about dum-dums
lollipops cream soda
when i speak in japanese over here i
think it's the most disgusting
soda to ever or drink to everything i'll
drink prune juice before i drink creams
you got uh you got uh
you got some deep-rooted issues with
some of this stuff i don't understand
why it's not deep rooted it's i i have
i have taste buds and my taste buds
don't like certain things and i'm
telling you cream soda stinks
vanilla what i love to do with vanilla i
make myself a bowl of ice cream i did
this since i'm a kid
you talk about how i like a vanilla
shake a lot of that is scoop of vanilla
in the milk and all the other stuff
and you so i get my ice cream i just let
it melt
i just let it melt i look at it and i
desire it and i build up
this excitement that i'm gonna have it
but i wait until it's
melted as a matter of fact to speed up
the process i put the spoon in
and i go like this and then it gets i
start to whip it it gets lighter and
lighter and lighter and lighter until it
becomes basically a nice cold vanilla
soup
and then i and i sip the vanilla the ice
cold vanilla liquid
off the spoon i don't do that with
chocolate no human being on earth does
what you just described
you're my sister did it well look i
don't know what to tell you we all did
it what you just described
sounded to me you don't like when the
ice cream melts if you're eating out of
a pint
and the edges get really liquefied and
melty first and when you instead of the
center when you you don't go to the side
with your spoon
and pull up the really chicken like a
hobo would do on thanksgiving like that
would be a hobo's thanksgiving meal
is he would go oh boy we're gonna eat
tonight and he would melt his ice cream
down
and then pretend he was eating a fancy
soup
here's something i don't agree with with
you you don't like to
to to eat foods and try foods in
different ways
you can call it a cop out to the food
which i think it's one of the complex
variations of the food i think it's one
of the benefactors of what you could do
with the food
i could eat ice cream hard i could eat
ice cream soft i could twist an oreo i
could not and you're like well if you've
got a twister no no no
no no no no no no no no no you're you're
you're you're confusing things here
i do like to eat foods in different
variations i do appreciate it
but when we're talking about the raw
base quality of one food versus the
other and
and you have to rely on the variation of
that food to win
that's where i go no that's not a better
i was letting my my vanilla melt
relying on a variation to win i'm saying
every
almost everything you've said so far
about vanilla ice cream when i go
every time i have an online screen it
has to be paired with something that's
you
and you but but my point is is you said
because it's awesome because it's great
because i say nope it's because it's it
raises up no it's not it raises up all
the other ingredients it enhances
everything
vanilla you know what the ingredients
singing in the vanilla you raise me up
so i can stand on mountains
so so here's my thing if if i said to
you
uh steak is the best meat
all right and you went yeah and then i
and i said you know
i love steak uh with cheese i love steak
with barbecue sauce i love
then all of a sudden it's kind of like
well steak maybe isn't the best meat
because every time you say you like it
you got to put something on it
okay you are so full of
crap okay because the only two of the
only times we had this argument is right
now with the vanilla
you're the one who said every time i
have to have it i put something on it i
didn't say that
i said i eat it plain and i see many
people but i said the reason
people do that is because vanilla goes
with everything and it
uplifts everything then you are making
that my argument why vanilla is good
that's not what i said
you said it and when i said oreo adding
cheese to a steak or this to a steak is
not the same thing as choosing
to eat my oreo cream first twist on not
twist
you're applying it's just the oreo i'm
just eating the main ingredients i'm
just deciding
how i want to eat it and you are saying
that
somehow makes it a negative thing i
think it's a positive one
one of your arguments with the oreo was
that you put them in milk
and drink them okay which is another
another hobo meal that you do and i
don't understand
you're right joe you're right i am i am
out in hobo
city dunkin cookies and milk nobody but
hobos
dunks their cookies and milk that's me
and i should just have
i put all my cookies in the bindle and i
just it's clear
it's clear we are going to come nowhere
near even it's another thing by the way
dunking listen we'll get to it don't
get to it yeah we will we will we will
get to it obviously and we are not going
to come anywhere near agreeing and we
are at wella time
so let's go to the polls let's go to the
polls let's see i gotta be honest you
know you pick just like apple pie
chocolate is king don't backbone i don't
know right now you're going to be
surprised don't backpedal now going to
be surprised
okay here we go
here we go
[Music]
okay right now we have hold on who's
somebody's eating humble pie though
right this our segment has come
this is the humble pie segment all right
where somebody's got to eat some humble
pie
and it because you got it why it's funny
someone has to eat humble pie uh what do
you what do you think the percentage is
gonna be don't pull it up yet
i think it's gonna be a slaughtering
with chocolate in the wind
i think chocolate is in the 80
percentile 80 percent
somewhere in the 80s that's what i think
okay
so as of right now we have uh 2 500
votes okay
and uh
we have a winner okay it's closer than
that
okay i told you that it would be okay uh
right now we have
56 to 44 which is
which is relatively close i think we
said that if something closed out on a
poll
within two percent it could have a
rematch yeah yeah so we're
near rematch territory but it's goddamn
vanilla baby
you son of a i told you i
told you i told you two thousand cups
100 votes
you got vanilla in the lead you didn't
want to listen this is the biggest upset
we've had so far
chocolate had every right to win because
people i told you when it comes to
vanilla people when it comes to ice
cream people change their pallets
they change it people like generally
like vanilla ice cream more than
chocolate ice cream
look look at your big powerhouse your 80
percent powerhouse
is in the 43 now 43.9
to 56.1 let's read some of
eat the pie i eat the humble pie no this
is the hugest update don't just go
listen don't just go to them yet don't
just go to them all right you got to
give this
it's respect because this was this is an
upset this is this is one of the biggest
episodes we've had but i
not to me because i knew i knew i
knew that people love vanilla ice cream
vanilla ice cream is more popular than
chocolate ice cream
even in stores vanilla based items are
more popular
vanilla i'm telling you vanilla is king
when it comes to ice cream
it was a misconstrued this is something
misconstrued it says best classic ice
cream flavor
and big surprise the tenderloins fan
club agreed with sal
i think they know what you like they
don't oh yeah they've been watching you
on tv for 12 years right
i think they know you're right at least
once a season i go i talk about vanilla
ice cream i'm sure it's come up before
oh my god i mean
joe it's 2 500 votes not one person
you're looking at the ten loins fan club
i mean it's 20 by just take the goddamn
ass kicking
let's read them let's read them go ahead
that's just an upset i'm upset i'm angry
this is ridiculous i'm angry vanilla is
just boring
says somebody always got to pick the
winner always default to yeah we got
we're going to pick the best comment in
the win
uh we're going to pick the best comment
we actually people we got to we people
need to know about that because we're
doing it
but they don't know about it but it's
fine all right always default to vanilla
or soft serve twist
vanilla hands down for me vanilla has so
much range
obvi and beautiful subtleties
thinking vanilla is plain is a noob
sense of taste
vanilla makes all of your baked goods
better it is the salt of sweets vanilla
even makes your chocolate better
anyway vanilla ice cream all the way
vanilla peen
goat okay oh she just said i'm gonna say
hold on don't scroll yet let me tell you
i have
i have a connection to the people that
listen to this pocket
that was basically my entire argument
she just summed up in her tweet
i'm gonna shout out i'm gonna wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait no we only
shout out the winner
i will say this but honestly that is a
great i will say this
she has my vote for winner already
unless somebody tops that that's the
winner
that's the winner response but but don't
shout her out just yet
all right let's keep going vanilla has
more add-on opportunities you can only
add so much to chocolate and still be
good
vanilla is endless sing it sisters and
brothers because
this is what i was telling you didn't
want to listen to me maybe you listen to
the people
i've never listened to the people which
is why i'm where i'm at in my career
how about this one this is this is
insightful
this is insightful chocolate is my
favorite
but vanilla goes with everything so
vanilla wins
you can't that means chocolate wins if
you say
chocolate is your favorite then that
means chocolate wins
that's a ridiculous the only right
answer is vanilla vanilla beans
specifically
and by the way look over and over mike
you can see it over and over again
the same argument but you can put
vanilla with so many things
so what so what you can do with the salt
with so many things i don't want to eat
a bowl of salt
how is vanilla beating chocolate with a
britney spears con confusing
gif i like that is it giffords
nobody knows ever chocolate is my
favorite but vanilla goes oh you already
read that one
rocky road man people once you see these
episodes
you'll know we're making this request
don't tell us a third thing
it's not cute we don't yeah vanilla
chocolate rocky road
nobody wants this guy is doing his own
joker's
poll in the middle of our food poll
obviously vanilla and if you say
chocolate you would drop the joker's
pull at 57
on his own twitter feed big surprise the
uh all right
uh obviously vanilla and if you say
chocolate you were dropped on your head
all right y'all are fake chocolate is
the only right answer
only also vanilla has for most of its
short commercial history involved child
labor
where's the pistachio butt all right our
winner is
vanilla is just boring let's shout out
our
chocolate ice cream is effing trash and
i will fight people to death on
yes let's shout out our winner that that
woman that
won spa gouter shout outs to spa gooder
she's you can follow her at
babe gorgeous babe look she's even got
babe in the title
at babe gorgeous babe uh and she
won with with the i mean god that's i
mean it's just
we didn't have anyone that really it's
usually the winner is someone that
provided provided us the biggest laugh
so far but this one is just such a
well-rounded out
it's an efficient argument contained in
one tweet i think it really
she's right she's right about everything
she said i might get this tattooed on me
this is and let's just just just for
good measure let's just make sure
that vanilla is still winning yeah it is
i mean it's 55.45 now but it's 3 000
votes
this one hurts i'm not gonna lie this is
one biggest
80 20. this was here's the thing i'm
i'm aggravated right now yeah this was
the first debate too
where and i don't know if you if you
could feel it mike there was some real
venom there was some real venom in this
one
uh there was some real they were it was
getting heated so i'm
i'm upset about this one so let's end
the episode
and move on to the next episode yeah
which i'm going to win
uh plugs plugs uh
and then we'll sign off yeah is that
outro before plugs oh that's right
before well if it is look i know this
was that i know there was some animosity
here
today but i still love it i love you too
all right all right taste buddies uh if
you want to hear even more of me
debating things uh i have a news podcast
to do with corinne fisher it's called
without a country
get it at the gas digital network use
promo code wac for a free month
uh of to their subscription uh and all
their shows and also pat walsh and i do
a podcast where we review movies called
we'll see you in hell
and get new episodes at patreon.com
w-s-y-i-h
podcast and uh the back catalog
is wherever you get your shows from yes
any and all dates that i do on the road
will be at savilecanocomedy.com
uh and uh yeah i mean actually the
the shows are about gonna be back on tv
soon but if you're a if you're a buddy
are you also a baby because i got a
podcast with krista steveno called hey
babe
uh also on this channel so if you
haven't checked it out check that out as
well
and uh that's it we got a hot one next
too right
stay tuned taste buds they coming to the
mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs
taste buds taste buds better put on your
boots make sure they're laced up what
does that have to do with it